[Music]
don't press snooze smooth doesn't help
fellow snooze is one of those things
that just seems a dream killer yeah it's
like a sisters bought nine kilograms
that score that's the truth
yeah it's like a complete think it's
gonna help you dream more when it's not
commit destroy your dreams it's a
psychological trick if you must lose the
thing that you think pressing the snooze
helps you with like I'll just get that
extra eight minutes to sleep that eight
minutes to sleep daily to be anywhere
energy by the way 18 seconds there's if
there's an 18 second window in the
morning when your alarm goes off that
sucks
it's about 18 seconds so 18 think the
alarm goes off in you touch it yeah the
next 18 seconds are like a hard there
that's when you have to use maximum
effort to clear the gravitational pull
of your pillow if you can get away from
those 18 seconds then you're okay you
just get get away from the pillow it's
pulling you in oh yeah some tractor beam
I need to get away from that donkey so
the 18 seconds and once you're up and
moving you're good
[Music]